سقف الدعم الغربي لاوكرانيا ما فتح يرتفع
شيئا فشيئا فبعد الدبابات والصواريخ بعيده
المدى جاءت دور ربما على مقاتلات اف 16
الموضوع بات مطروحا بشكل علني بعد انشاء
حلفاء غربيين التحالفا دوليا لانجاز
الصفقه لكن تسليم المقاتل الامريكيه
الشهيره الى كاذ يمر او لا عبر موافقه
واشنطن المتردده حتى الان صحيفه
ذكرت ان اداره بايدن وان تجاوزت العديد من
الخطوط الحمراء في مساعداتها الى كاذب الا
انها لا تزال تتمسك برفضها ارسال طائرات
مقاتله حديثه ويبدو بان القرار سيحسم في
الاسابيع الخليه القادمه وهو ما اعلن عنه
الامين العام لحلف الناتو
والذي قال ان تسليم المقاتلات الغربيه
لاوكرانيا
سيناقش خلال اجتماع وزراء دفاع الناتو
الشهر المقبل
يقال مشاهدينا ان افضل طريقه للدفاع هي
الهجوم ويبدو انك بدات تتبع هذه الخطه
لقلب الطاوله على روسيا معطيات عديده تشير
الى ان القوات الاوكرانيه غيرت من
استراتيجيتها في الحرب وباتت تبادر
بالهجوم هذا ما اكدته صحيفه
انتقلت من مرحله الدفاع الى الهجوم تقول
الصحيفه ان اوكرانيا باتت تشن هجمات تهدف
الى تدمير مخازن الذخيره ومخابئ الامدادات
التي تحتاجها القوات الروسيه وتراكات ان
هذه الهجمات النوعيه والدقيقه ستكون اكثر
فاعليه من مواجهه تقليديه امام القوات
الروسيه ما يفسر رغبتكاف في استهداف نقاط
اكثر عمقا هو طلبها المتزايد في الحصول
على مسيرات وصواريخ بعيده المدى من
الخلفاء الغربيين كما ترغب في انهاك
القوات الروسيه بانتظار وصول المزيد من
الاسلحه الغربيه لشن هجومها المضاد الكبير
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات